let's go shopping when I talk about
eating healthy eating plant-based one of
the first things people say to me is I'd
love to do that but this is too
expensive and that's because there is
this idea this powerful entrenched idea
that healthy eating healthy lifestyle
the vegan lifestyle is something that is
reserved for the well-heeled elite only
but is this really true well to find out
my son Trapper and I decided to hit up
some markets around town and see what we
could get for $25 or less ready to make
a video
yes Phillip yeah all right you can't
them in there guys sorry
so at everyone we picked up two fresh
pressed juices sorry I drank this one
and trot no I drank this one trop or
drank this one and a grand total for
this outing was $24 $24 for two juices
next stop Gelson's thank you all right
we did a little bit better at Gelson's
instead of two juices this time we got
three three Suge's the grand total for
this outing was twenty four twelve
twelve cents more one extra juice next
stop Whole Foods in the superfood
section I love goji berries like huger
berries goji berries are great
are you going drink
thank you here's where we got it Whole
Foods
one bag of goji berries and the grand
total for this outing was 26 99 so that
was kind of a failure we went over our
budget by almost $2 for what is
essentially dried fruit exotic dried
fruit delicious dried fruit very
nutritious dried fruit but nonetheless
dried fruit it is really good though all
right let's huddle up and take a
half-time break at this point you must
be thinking man I'm going to have to be
making some serious Bank in order to be
vegan or you know just dial up my plate
and eat more plant powered or healthy
well look if you buy all your foods at
fancy high-end markets places like we
have out here in California like
Gelson's and erawan and Whole Foods then
yeah that's the deal it is going to be
expensive it can be very expensive all
the way to downright completely
unaffordable for most people especially
if you're not paying attention or you're
overly focused on crazy specialties
super food items like the goji berries
we bought or you venture beyond the
simple basics like produce don't get me
wrong I'm not hating on places like
Whole Foods I love me a nice high-end
market but you got to be selective about
what you get there and nobody said you
have to shop at any of these places in
order to be vegan or simply more focused
on eating healthy foods
next up Trader Joe's
do you think we're over a little bit
couple dollars what's your price
prediction
I'd say $28 28 because I'm going to eat
we might be a little over he made it
were under 25 a good job thank you so
much thanks Louis produce and a
pineapple all this at Trader Joe's for a
grand total of
24:43 under budget alright we're going
off the beaten path a little bit for
this one unchartered territory this
place before never
yeah it's trip can you leave that Wow
that'd be bad I'm pretty freaking head
mom
20 pounds of rice four pounds of red
kidney beans your mom shops in here all
the time you know that really yeah not
but you never look I just need to thank
you we killed it at the Indian market
twenty pound bag of rice 4 pound bag of
kidney beans a family of four can eat on
this for like a week
with this much rice and beans you can
make chili you can make vegan burritos
it provides the basis for a billion
different healthy recipes grand total
$24.99 one cent under budget
Trevor of you ever been in for two can't
say I have
it's going to be interesting let's go
find out
Kocher profits yeah okay all right
thanks no problem we got shut down so
we're gonna resort to plan B let's put
this back and regroup are you kidding me
grand total at vr de 2368
granted this was hardly some kind of
hardcore exhaustive research project
that controlled for all variables I was
just having fun and there are plenty of
items at places like Whole Foods that
are more affordable than the items that
we selected and vice-versa the foods we
sourced at the lower end markets aren't
organic and they're not locally grown
and I'm well aware that there are plenty
of farmers markets and coops and other
grocery stores and grocery store chains
that we didn't visit but I think I made
my point if you missed it it goes like
this
the idea that eating plant-based is just
too expensive
that's just contempt prior to first-hand
investigation it's just lazy if you do
it right and you do it smart I think
you'll be really surprised you could
dial up your plate in ways that can make
it even cheaper than eating
conventionally so don't buy into the
hype
trapper time to work sorry